they're also this really loud voice in
the culture war have to be you know you
have to be I refuse to let lies go
unchallenged
I refuse to let anti logic go
unchallenged anti logic like what like
did you don't need secure borders really
so the Democrats don't think we need to
secure our borders right and the
Democrats don't admit there's a
difference between legal immigration and
illegal immigration let me give you a
little metaphor if you go to the bank
and withdraw from your account you're a
legal banker if you go to the bank and
draw from someone else's account you're
a bank robber there is a division there
were four legal banking were not for
illegal banking and this kind of anti
logic is weaseled its way into policy
and it's just tragic with a multi
trillion dollar debt and unsecured
borders and we're worried about
separating families well we fail to say
if you're going to come here come
legally or we will send you back we sent
on a message have at it just go ahead
and swim across the damn River well do
you personally have a problem when they
separate families because well sure I'm
a father and a grandfather yeah I [ __ ]
up but the real [ __ ] starts with the
the the insane irresponsibility of
daring to subject your children to that
I don't think they have any choice of
not dinner over there then living in
because Mexico and Guatemala is one big
gang infested government military law
enforcement [ __ ] yeah yeah if you
call it a [ __ ] I'm racist well if it
wasn't a [ __ ] they would stay it is
a [ __ ] you ever been there
well some of Mexico some of Mexico
hasn't been raped and pillaged yet but
give them time they'll make it they're
murdering and raping and in brutalizing
people I mean it's just a hellhole
there's definitely some bad things
happen and a lot of it is because the
drug war out of control yeah and a lot
of people think that the remedy to that
is legalizing drugs and taxing man yeah
yeah we like it so they mean the same
thing with prohibition the same thing
that would happen in America would be
really boosted organized crime and Al
Capone and they got a stronghold because
of the money they were making from
illegal
drugs I just alcohol at the time I think
that right now that the spoiled brat
epidemic in this country if you don't
get everything you want you start
shooting people or you cut people off
and road rage if everything doesn't go
just right everybody is so touchy and so
pussified that when I was growing up
sticks and stones may break your bones
but words will never hurt me what do you
think that's coming from the
liberalisation of policy and the the
horrible lie of the welfare dream that
people who need a helping hand
are always given a helping hand by
neighbors and family and friends and if
they have them yeah well the Catholic
Church has eight trillion dollars just
in jewelry they could probably provide
some sandwiches and blankets so there's
plenty of help available but when you
get into a system and you you play on
the people's emotions that we need a
safety net these poor people are
destitute they need help okay let's
create a welfare where we can help these
destitute people meanwhile it's infested
with scammers and bloodsuckers and Liars
who were able-bodied and they just don't
want to stop it to help want a sign they
want some of your income because you're
stupid enough to get up early and work
really hard and they don't want to
that's pandemic so meanwhile the people
who are truly needy they slip through
the cracks
we don't even get to know who they are
and in the liberal policy of eliminating
the heartbreak in the disrespect of
Cuckoo's Nest we can't we can't call
them mental health centers we might hurt
some feelings so now what are they doing
they're putting spikes and boards and
attacking people walking their dog in LA
yeah there's no place for them to go
when I was growing up there's a place in
Detroit called Eloise it was a nut house
and that's the Cuckoo's Nest that's
where if you were mentally ill and you
needed help that there was a place for
you to go to get you off the streets so
you don't attack people with spikes and
do by force what are you talking about
the spikes and too much guy right here
right down the street here one days ago
yeah tacked some fashion photographer
walking his dog and hit him in the head
with a 2x4 with a spike and almost
killed him in a and a citizen I didn't
even hear mouths oh yeah awesome citizen
jumped up in the air caught this guy
with both feet right in the neck
not beat the [ __ ] out of that's nice oh
there's a rare occasion of Justice
pro-wrestling come in handy but yes but
that that incident is not rare where you
go to San Francisco and the mental
health institution isn't supposed to be
the streets the mess is a good example
of too much liberal policy you get
people that are a little bit too
progressive and tools now for the rest
of that's regressive I don't know how
did they ever utilize that term that's
bastardized that's what progressive it
gets so far that it becomes regressive
when you're letting bums [ __ ] all over
the streets but I think you I think that
would be an indicator so like there's so
the ideas that just like these poor
people leave them alone you know they're
fine they just you know they it's okay
if they live on the streets but if you
go to San Francisco they're very
aggressive it's it's one of the weirder
places I've ever been in terms of
homeless people and one of the most part
broad unquote progressive places in our
country
yeah it's one of the most progressive
cities heartbreaking yeah we need more
Cuckoo's Nest but even those
institutions the corruption and the
abuse of power that runs rampant a nurse
cratchit I mean that that that that
wasn't just a fantasy a script that that
happens the irresponsibility and in in
pharmaceutical problem and then they
increase the mental problem with big
farm yeah I mean I've had personal
experiences with that with the dear
friends of mine that we're having mental
problems and they end up in an
institution and then their mental
problems are exasperated by chemical
warfare upon them you know what I was
growing up how old are you John fifty
fifty just a boy when I was growing up
there's this this mantra this
colloquialism better living through
chemistry
yeah and in many ways it is I mean we
saved tens of millions of lives in
Africa with DDT by killing the tsetse
fly and we saved tens of millions of
people and then some environmentalists
came in and the DDT is a dangerous
chemical so they stopped it and we lost
tens of millions of people it's better
to kill a bunch of tsetse flies to save
human lives than to ban the DDT that
allows tsetse flies to flourish and kill
people so now it's gone full circle and
that's where the toxins have accumulated
and the the horrific waste that I had
texted Anthony just before he died
congratulating him Han is hosting that
brilliant documentary if you haven't
seen it yet its waste waste exclamation
point what we do to our foods in this
country and the the self-inflicted
scourge of toxification of our precious
environment so there's not a lot of easy
answers but here it is 28th of June 2018
and here you and I are at least
discussing this stuff to millions of
people I suspect and I see upgrade
taking place I see upgrade in awareness
not fast enough to make me happy but
enough to indicate I mean an upgraded
prognosis for people's awareness
accountability responsibility where are
you seeing this
whether it's you know like the circles
that you travel the circles certainly
and we don't waste one of my biggest pet
peeves is little fat kids that you know
take a sip of $2 bottle of water and
then they leave it there and then the
thrown it away and that the waste is
pandemic in this country and I see my
kids are like like stormtroopers they're
like drill sergeants with that we just
don't want to waste and we've always
recycled and the jury is still out
whether that has any effect at all but
the the the disconnect and
unconscionable misbehavior of just
tossing and throwing away everything you
know what drives me [ __ ] crazy
cigarettes out the window oh people just
went the people that smoke cigarettes
for whatever reason did have a problem
throwing it on the ground I'm probably
wouldn't litter
how about would drive me crazy there's
somebody still stupid enough to buy
cancer yeah you're here let me invest in
the companies that want to kill me here
here's a couple extra thousand dollars
kill more of us
you dumb do you MHz cool it makes the
don't think so man what never so much